you were saying that seven percent of
dementia happens in guys 40 and 50s it's
a genetic thing and it just happens and
that's what happened Bruce Willis I
guess I mean you don't know his case or
maybe you do but that's kind of the
indication right that he got this
genetic Dimension the dementia he has
this frontal temporal which it says
where it is in the brain that kind of
dementia it certainly can be genetic and
that's very worrisome you know at the
same time get a load of this this is the
wildest study ever done Google bought
the ancestry.com database and they
sequenced all the genes and they said
Hey listen let's find the gene for
longevity because I want you know they
wanted to make people live longer and
what percent of longevity do you think
is genetic you tell me
which means
96 is in your control that to me is the
most positive study in the world you can
charge your own health so the genetics
only count four percent that's it right
it's your behavior you're in charge of
you and I think that's powerful listen
dementia is horrible it is one of the
most difficult things to watch in a
loved one but we can't measure this
organ the brain at all right we don't
have a way of looking at brain function
that is very accurate and there's a
problem there probably the most
important organ in our body to Define us
as a human and we can't measure it we
don't know how it works I don't know how
the brain works and that's very
frustrating and so most of these
dementias the Alzheimer's and the others
we don't really know yet why they happen
we can't really understand them there's
some amazing observations and this is
one that I talk to you about all the
time is every year you delay retirement
you reduce the incidence of Alzheimer's
by almost three and a half to four
percent so a twenty year span that could
be a sixty to seventy percent reduction
in the incidence of Alzheimer's you need
to make yourself uncomfortable every day
you don't use it you lose it is real
make yourself uncomfortable going to
work it challenges your brain but you're
right these guys retire and then the
brain turns to Mush we all know the
people who are functional to the 90s and
whatever they're engaged they don't have
to do their primary job but they're
doing something that gets them out of
their comfort zone and that's what's key
how many people retire and just sit
around and play golf or just you know
watch TV they don't do very well I look
at Mick Jagger the guy's almost 80 years
old
he looks to me like he's in really good
shape he moves around like a young man
he goes into dance studios and dances
every day dances around that's got to be
difficult at his age but it probably
keeps them young it keeps them you write
it probably does something internally
by pushing past his comfort zone he's
engaged he has enough money I am sure to
retire but he doesn't do that he keeps
pushing every time he has an album out
he puts himself out for potential
failure and that's always has to be
scary every artist that comes up with
something is afraid that somebody won't
like it right and that gets that
adrenaline going and he gets
uncomfortable he keeps doing that and
that's what keeps him going every time
you do a show you and Robin you put
yourselves out there for people to
potentially criticize it and that
uncomfortableness if you will is what
keeps you engaged and going and that's
important
foreign